the flow of people leaving ukraine
continues unabated
resident christianity's mind is miles
away at the romanian border with ukraine
where thousands of refugees have been
gathering you can imagine they're
completely exhausted they're confused
they have no idea what's going on he's
going there to help he leaves sunday to
join his brother sebastian we're about
three kilometers from the border who
runs a canadian-based charity pilgrim
movement
sebastian says they've been in the area
for weeks i am
providing a corridor
a safe corridor for refugees especially
mothers with children and elderly people
and i'm also focusing on the african
students that are stuck here at the
board there he and his volunteers are
providing food housing and
transportation at four border crossings
i have
corridors towards western europe
towards italy france spain
germany england and ireland
according to him connections in canada
are in the works the problem christian
points out is that the refugee issue
will get worse quickly
according to unicef nearly 140 000
ukrainian citizens entered romania since
russia invaded ukraine what are you
going to do next week when there's going
to be a wave of another a hundred
thousand and in two weeks when it's
going to be five hundred thousand
he plans to help his brother with the
logistics and they're appealing to the
public for help especially for
accommodation and transportation to the
refugees country of choice we take
daughter dog only documents and left
the canadian government has two special
programs to assist ukrainian nationals
to come to canada prime minister justin
trudeau said he's not ruling out
airlifts as an option for refugees
christian and his brother hope they get
the help they need this project they say
is close to their heart thirty-two years
ago
i was a refugee myself he fled romania
during the revolution now he's returning
to help others fleeing another conflict
phil carpenter global news volderadorian